okay guys this week the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences which
Awards the Oscars announced that in 2019
they will add a new award category
called popular film now it sounds like
this move is intended to be more
inclusive in the Oscar ceremony with
movies that general audiences actually
watch in large numbers and increase
ratings on the Oscars telecast itself
which is hit a ratings low this past
year the Academy said eligibility
requirements and other key details of
the popular film category will be
forthcoming but people have already
begun to speculate that this couldn't
mean commercial hits like Black Panther
and Avengers infinity war could get
recognized they are probably the most
profitable films of this year
historically the Oscars tend to snub
blockbusters and super rare movies like
remember the Dark Knight was famously
overlooked and that that actually caused
them to expand best picture to 10
possible nominees I mean while there are
some high grossing movies that have
broken through in the past to get Best
Picture like Titanic and Lord of the
Rings return to the king and many many
other popular films have actually gotten
nominated and last year a lot of these
popular films that would have been
nominated may be won for other awards
technical words just not the big top
usually like costume designs custom
design visual effects sound design and
then of course over the years there have
been movies like you know get out and
gravity and Mad Max fury road an
inception and all the Pixar movies they
tend to get nominated some said that if
this award was available last year we
would have seen nominations for movies
like Logan and Wonder Woman in it so
just imagine that kind of lamp that'd be
kind of cool to see a category where
those movies are competing against each
other so overall do you guys think this
is a good idea if it means movies like
Black Panther and infinity war get
recognized by the Academy finally and
what other movies this year do you think
should be considered for this new
category popular film second one first
Mission Impossible fallout yeah oh so
great yes it doesn't get nominee one of
the best action films ever if they are
gonna make this stupid category then
like like be like okay well it still has
to be like a really good blockbuster
movie and that was you know it wasn't
skyscraper
just saying yeah I'm still mad don't
even bother no no yeah I think that it's
kind of nice that the Academy is
starting to recognize that they're just
a bit out of touch I mean this has been
indicative with the Oscars so white the
last few
now the fact that you know the same kind
of person it's like is winning a lot of
the time and that it's like you know
400,000 people see a movie that we've
never really heard of I'm not dissing
phantom thread but it's like you know
you got all this love and attention but
I'd say everyone I spoke she wasn't
watching it so unless you're Alicia
Malone so well I just kind of like that
it's like you know we are paying
attention to what is mainstream and you
know we're kind of catching up with the
times a little bit more instead of being
stuck in this sort of stuffy closet
which is all about moons Newt yeah but
at the same time I don't like the
corruption that's behind this decision
because obviously well an actress that
gets put on a Mickey Mouse you know if
an actor and actress wins the best
academy for best actor or actress their
rate skyrockets and so it is you know
the prestige behind winning the award
and the accolade behind it means that
you can increase money so do they really
need sort of like more of a reason to
get its I mean money drives all this
stuff right ABC is it sounds like
they're the ones who are pushing these
changes because they host the Oscars
telecast and they're promising and we'll
make it a shorter show will put more
movies in there that general audiences
would have seen so ratings will they be
good sell more and better advertising
they're they're moving they're more
boring things - behind the commercials
that said I guess I'll play contrarian
today that'll be my role I I don't know
that we need this category I think it
kind of is like crappy that I people are
already calling it the popcorn Oscar
which just is like well thanks for
making me feel bad about an Oscar and
then it's like so the the Dark Knight
should have been nominated obviously but
also theirs is stupid I saw a gif that
kind of like change my thoughts on this
and it was just it was a gift for as a
picture something but it said like
everything is all ready for you this one
thing is for them and I kind of was like
you know what what does an Avengers
infinity war have no I mean like it's
like maybe it won't have an Oscar but
it's like but then
thread does have an Oscar and they don't
have anything else so I kind of get that
like maybe the Oscars aren't supposed to
be mainstream maybe they're supposed to
be like how we should all pay more
attention to the Arts and stuff
I've always been pressured I mean I was
super hurt by the Dark Knight not being
nominated that year but I think that is
more about stigma than like they need to
find a backdoor in got it I just want
more actual great films nominated
including superhero films and comedies
and Horrors get out yeah great yeah I
mean I see that I think I kind of go
back and forth right because like if it
had existed last year get out probably
would have won that category
it wouldn't maybe wouldn't have been
nominated or had a chance at Best
Picture and a movie this year like Black
Panther infinity war or fallout would I
feel like the way they kind of separated
right now with Animated Feature right
they created the Animated Feature
category 91 Beauty and the Beast won
Best Picture and we were thinking well
of Animated Feature existed then it
wouldn't have even been in the they
would have separated it but ultimately I
think like it's easy because I feel like
I'm in a bubble with my friends and
we're all like living in Hollywood and
we go to Arclight and like going to the
movie theater is often like oh yes we'll
get our movie screeners or what we want
to see in the big screen we'll see
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 a Space Odyssey
and analyze it after it and it's easy to
be in that bubble even though but I love
infinity war I love like it I look I
think there's there's celebration worth
having for all movies that do really
well and connect with people and a movie
like Jumanji came out the new one with
the rock and we loved it I think if
you're looking at the craft in the
tradition that is Hollywood filmmaking I
think you need to celebrate all
different kinds of movies including ones
that might that critics might thumb
their nose is that as being just too
broad but most people really enjoy I
just don't want to get into MTV
territory I think they really just text
this number and vote for your favorites
popularity contest no no no this is an
awards we want a group of parents so
people cheat no good because I think the
MTV thing's a joke and most of the stars
don't even bother going anymore so yeah
I don't
they're trying to dissolve what MTV has
done with their awards and it's just
like I'm not entirely sure it sounds
like they are trying to expand their
demographic and have Kody 13 the Oscars
I'm curious to see what the eligibility
requirements are do they determine it by
box-office gross - they determine it by
budget of the movie right yeah like well
maybe submit yourself I guess a little
bit and I real quick on the note you
were saying like you can technically
still be nominated for Best Picture
but Erik's not wrong in that we all know
that a lot of times people get the Oscar
nomination like because of some other
reason like it's their time or that kind
of nonsense so I definitely think you're
right they're like you know what we
should done Best Picture but we have a
new category let's just do that I think
you're right it actually will the Oscar
said no it could be nominated for both I
think you're more right it probably
won't get nominated but I think what's
good about it though is we'll have a
category where these chances where these
movies have a real chance at winning the
top version of that award great so
people are now tuning into the broadcast
just to see whether it's infinity war
black panther which is kind of an
interesting thing for fans to tune in on
but if it is here's here's one thing on
the side of doing it give Marvel some
freaking Oscars and maybe the other
people will finally be like okay fine
we'll do it the right way we'll make it
good because it'll be Marvel's
oscar-winning like Iron Man 6 yeah you
know I mean versus you know I think what
it could encourage is these creators of
superhero movies to do more movies like
Black Panther and Logan you know like
more heartfelt thematically I think
infinity war was a very thematic journey
of sacrifice that you saw Thanos and
mostly other characters make I think if
more superhero movies are made with that
kind of like emotional gut punch I think
that's a good thing and if an award
category on something like the Oscars
ceremony does that I think it could be a
really good incentive for directors of
those movies to really focus on what do
these movies mean and how can I really
have an emotional effect on the audience
which I think it lifts the tide for all
the ships
yeah I agree I'm gonna put you guys on
the spot real quick give it to Black
Panther
fenerty wore black panther I would say
Black Panther just because I there's if
any war monger was an amazing than not
taking away from fairness but I think
that having Michael B Jordan in there
was incredible the costume design what
they did with like culture in itself
yeah yeah I for me black night there's
more of a true film
whereas if any more feels like more than
a film I think there might be a cop-out
but I know it's true you can't it's not
fair I actually enjoyed infinity war
more to be honest but Black Panthers a
standalone movie that's very good
infinity war is like a cap like epilogue
kind of thing like it would it had to do
the fact that it works at all is amazing
yeah so but we shouldn't give to say
that's the best film yeah yeah that's
true well let us know what you think
about this new category if you have an
opinion at all and if you don't have an
opinion about the category which of
these where do you fall in this debate
of what is the most the best popular
film of the of the year because there
have been a lot of good movies that are
popular and have been very high-quality
critically speaking as well so let us
know what your thoughts are in the
comments below or tweet us all
individually